all right what's up everyone we are back
at the blockchain economic forum we are
with Tegan Kline hi great to be here
thanks for coming out of the show yeah
greatly appreciate it
so Tegan was teaching me about IP we to
the executive vice president of investor
relations there and when you initially
were like IP we and this is what we do I
was like okay wait a second this
directly applies to me because I care a
lot about patents and I look through the
US Patent and Trademark Office a lot
because we're constantly trying to
figure out invent people are
concentrating to invent and so you guys
have figured out a way leveraging
blockchain leveraging decentralization
technologies to make this a much easier
process because it's some archaic ass
technology that we're dealing with yeah
yeah teach us about it sure so we are
essentially democratizing the patent
space by creating a marketplace for
patents to transact so my CEO has been
in this space for about 15 years and
over the course of ten years he
developed an internal technology and he
put 80% of the world's patents on it so
currently today no global patent office
exists there are 2200 different patent
offices each country has their own so
we've scraped the data we've gone
through it we put it on our platform
called tooth analytics and we're giving
this away for free so right now if
you're an innovator you have two to two
different options you can either hire a
lawyer for thousands of dollars to
identify which patents exist in the
space that you're working in or how
expensive super expensive and then once
you once you get those eight once you
get six eighty page documents from your
lawyer what do you do with them so then
you have to hire an analyst to go
through them to figure out if if
anything's valid if if they're relevant
to your business at all so we've created
a platform using AI and deep learning so
that you don't need any humans to do
that and we're offering that for free
and then we've created another segment
to the business that allows you to
identify who owns the patents once you
identify which ones are relevant and
that's how you profitable no so that's
that's all offered for free and even the
businesses being able to figure out who
owns it's free it's it's all free and it
was about a twenty twenty million
dollars
into that so we're offering that for
free and that'll kind of drive platform
adoption to the marketplace so the only
time that we will make money is when a
transaction occurs on platform so for
example licensing acquisitions royalties
that are paid and it will take a small
piece of that in retrospect so we're
reducing the margins that currently
exist and raising a lot of the
transactions that will occur
all right let's unpack this this is this
is exciting stuff all right so 80% of
all patents that exist do you have on
record global so right now it's
segmented as in the United States
patents and trademarks are with the US
as office and then Europe's are in the
Europe's office and then I can't go to a
USPTO and look up your ups and compared
it to the US is okay wait a second you
have 80% of all of them but do you have
access to China's yes how does one even
begin to procure the China's vast swath
of patents so each Patent Office you can
access that data but one thing that
happens is a lot of it's like legacy
systems so you'll a lot of the times
will be on tape so what my CEO dad is he
had to go on eBay to buy a tape reader I
don't even know what a tape is what I
don't even know what that is what do you
mean they're gone so it's such a legacy
system a platform because patents are
relevant for about 20 years so 20 years
ago they didn't have ways to upload them
onto in the year 2000 they didn't have
the ability to upload documents
digitally or some of them just don't
they just don't it's it's government's
right and governments are still using
fax machine Merrick's fax machines only
people I know with fax machines are
lawyers and and government agents okay
so so so to decode what happened around
20 years ago use some of it some of
these are written on tapes and whatnot
okay and then so you're decoding and
uploading it into your system that's
already been done yeah so my CEO did
that over the course of the last ten
years so now all of that is on platform
and we've developed relationships with
the patent office
and our main focus is kind of the
smaller patent offices because they they
all have blockchain initiatives but they
can't really afford to do it so they
they use our Zeus analytics technology
and then they give us the patents that
they have okay so okay so so we went
from building relationships with over
the last 10 years with the patent
offices across the world and then taking
is the data is open source we the
patents because it is I can go to USPTO
and find whatever i okay and then I can
go to Europe's and find whatever I want
and I sometimes it be harder to tap into
like China's so then you have to build a
relationship and get all that data right
okay so then what is the largest holder
of patents currently yeah Wow you're
that Chinese alive so it'll hold ur
patents so okay so then you take all of
the patents on record and you put them
into IP we you said what's the Zeus
these analytics yes you can search it
all of the patents that exist any one of
your products is Zeus exactly yeah and
if you have a pine you can go to our
platform and you can upload it directly
and validate it on our platform so that
people always cover your patents as well
and you can license them out or if
you're not using the technology anymore
they can then be acquired so you're not
scrubbing the constant upload to
whatever it's uploaded to the USPTO are
you constantly scrubbing we yes we have
a team that does that still to this day
but we've done a lot of work to get
those at the 80% of patents that exist
on tarp ah that's a lot so also
otherwise after I submit a provisional
then I also submit it to you provisional
patent application I submit it to you as
well we don't deal anything with the
beginning stages of filing the pies it's
all after it's been filed or you can use
that you can utilize the patents that
exists exists currently so then when I
[Music]
might use the most common use cases are
for our platforms yes so one one large
aspect will be maintenance fees so each
year you pay
400 dollars on average on top of a 300
dollar maintenance fee just just to pay
simply pay a fee so you go through a
lawyer you go through a company like CPA
global to pay this and we're gonna
reduce that that fee that charge from
400 down to $30 on top of the $300 fee
that you're paying for what to a patent
renewal so each year when you hold a
patent you have to pay a maintenance fee
in order to keep it relevant patent
maintenance exactly it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous and think of these companies
that hold thousands of patents that are
paying so much money for bucks per year
700 700 per year 300 to pay the fee $400
for all the intermediaries that exist in
the space that are gouging them because
they're kind of taking advantage of the
transparency so hacia IP we where we're
kind of reducing there so currently
there are bad actors on both sides right
the the way the market exists
incentivizes bad actors on both sides so
you can't blame the individuals that are
taking advantage of the system you have
to change the system and that's what
we're doing ok so changing the systems
hopefully getting out getting out some
of the bad actors from the process and
the use case is to drop the yearly
renewal and maintenance to 30 bucks from
$700 that's fantastic and to have an
aggregated platform where I can just go
and tap into kind of the patent fabric
of our world I love that about it that's
great ok give me other relatable uses so
then royalties so right now you're
charged 5% or 500 basis points by
intermediaries to pay royalties
well we reduced that to about 1% or 50
basis points okay wait let's unpack that
so I've submitted a patent and my patent
is a patent that corporations want to
use so then I
I organized a licensing deal with them
and then but why would why would you get
a chunk of that ROI
see so that's the thing so we in order
to change the system someone needs to
build this but we don't think that we
should be at the center at the forefront
of this of this marketplace we think it
should be on owned essentially but we
need to change it and we need to make
the money to do that to change it first
so but but okay even if I even if my
patent exists on IP wheat yeah excuse me
and then you and then I make a licensing
deal with a corporation why can't what
where would I why would I pay you a fee
of that licensing deal as in would you
make the paperwork for it and everything
or like contracts on our platform so
it's done
oh so yeah oh so okay now I think that's
making more sense so then the the smart
contract is made on the decentralized
digital ledger and then the agreement
between the corporation and my and
myself on the patent is immutably made
forever for that period of time that
it's stamped for and you helped
facilitate that which is why you take a
percentage of the fee so you wrote the
smart contract between us yes and you
take 1% you said 1 percent or 50 basis
points 0.5% ok ok you point five to one
percent per like her licensing deal oh
oh [ __ ] so on every hundred dollars
you'd make a dollar exactly yeah ok
and that's just so you guys can sustain
and grow and continue prospering so is
this built on aetherium or is this
coated so we were looking at a theorem
initially it just was too expensive to
build on so we're actually using ipfs to
store the data and the hyper ledger
fabric to store the hash so one thing
that we have to offer to certain
companies is a permission network
because they certain companies aren't
willing to license to certain other
companies because of you know the I
guess I guess the difficulties are
between
them that exists right so we have to
offer them permissioned networks but
like universities they're more willing
to put their IP out to the world so
they'll have a permission list setting
oh yeah so I would have a permissionless
setting which would give access control
to anyone that wants it without royalty
they would be able to look at all of the
details within the within your patent
portfolio essentially yes and then but
then the access control would that would
that then enable them to use what I've
patented if my access control is free
open-source use it without even
contacting me right yeah I mean I'm sure
there's some legalities behind that I
guess yeah for your signing off rights
that you will never sue them for
infringing on your patent
but then what but then what if I
dynamically change it to be after a
couple months I'm like I want 1% of what
people like that licenses then how do we
go back and figure out who was using it
I guess it would have to be dependent on
what's in the support contract like the
duration of time the euros they still
have to say see there's still a smart
contract that has to be made I would say
so yes just to protect exactly the exact
scenario that you just yeah interesting
okay so what what are you most looking
forward to with IP wheat technology
across the world like how is this gonna
help with invention and globalization
and yeah so it'll remove a lot of patent
trolls that exists in the space it'll
eliminate a lot of the companies just
what is a patent troll a patent troll is
someone who just buys up a bunch of
patents and then goes after people for
infringing on their patents so they'll
still go out and sue which is my CEO
actually is a former patent troll that's
why he had an incentive to create all of
this but now he wants to give back to
the ecosystem and he sees all of the
flaws that exist so wow that's so much
work to buy patents and then go find
people that infringe on them and sue
them yeah but he turned $125,000 into
five hundred million dollars doing being
a patent troll yeah you only had he only
had to win like a couple major cases
in order to get a majority of that money
yeah but the thing is holy cow I know
but exactly so that's what we want to
change and we want to remove that
because that cripples people's business
is that like if you're like I what I was
saying earlier you have two choices of
the innovator hire a lawyer or hope that
you don't get sued for patent
infringement and that cripples your
business so that's kind of what I'm
looking forward to it's kind of giving
the power back to the innovators
removing that fear and also just
allowing people that don't have the
capital to hire those lawyers to
actually have access to obtaining
patents so in order to still file a
patent I stuff to file it with my
country exactly yes and any other
country that you want to have a
jurisdiction with you yes yes and then
so I still have to pay the the fees for
for creating the patent and then
submitting it through a legal entity so
one crazy statistic is that only 2% of
patents actually transact and that's a
hundred eighty billion dollar market
place and only 5% go into a commercial
product well two percent of pens
transact so like their license or their
acquired only 98 percent just sit
exactly it's so wasteful it's such a
wasteful space so that's what we want to
change oh so then you want to enable
those other 98% because yeah transact of
all yeah well that that is interesting
they bring that up well well maybe that
also is is just true about the the
uselessness of so many patents as well
yeah yeah
so but finding the ones that are useful
and then making them more applicable in
the world is important to ask okay what
else are you looking forward to what am
I patent trolls no more patent trolls
hopefully I guess also just bringing
kind of blockchain it's a good use case
for blocking right cuz we can tokenize
patents patent portfolios they can
become tradable it's it's allowing it's
giving liquidity to an asset class that
couldn't have before have liquidity
without blocking technology so I guess
that's what I'm looking forward to as
well
I love that giving liquidity to an a
socio-economic class that wasn't able to
gained it previously so okay how about
we ask you we ask a lot of questions on
this show some of them are we like to
call the like really thought-provoking
ones one of them that is really
difficult is about wealth and equality
and globalization you like got really
excited you're like okay give me your
difficult questions so what what do we
do like how do we balance the we are one
mentality with geopolitical leadership
and also how do we balance wealth being
exacerbated for the point 1 percent of
really fast versus the bottom which is
going rising very slowly yeah so I got
into blockchain initially for this very
reason I saw the possibilities to
provide resources to people that never
go before could have had it and
universal basic income is one thing
that's near and dear to my heart but I
just don't think the markets ready for
it yet and when it is I'll absolutely
100% be involved and have that as my
main goal and main initiative but right
now like capitalism is 100% failing us I
would argue that it's failing even the
top 1% hold on a second though there's
capitalism has done yeah absolutely it
needs a lot of tweaking but to an extent
I think you know I think one thing we're
gonna move from this kind of money based
money gives you power society into more
of a knowledge gives you power and I
think it's high dose it's gonna the
power is gonna be transferred from money
to knowledge but the thing is when when
money when power was transferred from
land to money a lot of horrible things
happen there was a lot of bloodshed so
we need to find a way to transfer that
power in a efficient way without harming
a lot of people in the process yeah I
think like you just described there's
like the transfer of power that that
those words transfer of power that's a
lot of kind of what ends up being the
conversational point about answering
this question because the
transfer of power can either be nice and
gentle and kind or it can be very bloody
and war and money and greedy and power
II and in egotistical and so I think one
of the ways that we've been talking
about on the show a lot you know you
mentioned ubi and it's like really
important to figure out how to best
bring that to our world if that ends up
being a case because robotics and AI are
here you know and they're a lot of work
is being taken away a lot of new jobs
are being made but you know people need
to be actualized in to this world still
at the same time and so and we can't
fight it we need to embrace it and
accept it and adopt with it and that's
why I'm excited about watching because I
think it's going to provide those
resources to people once their jobs are
taken from and and given to AI right
they can actually focus on doing things
that they really enjoy doing and not
just what gives them money so do the
things that we really enjoy doing not
just things that give us money that's
good that's good
okay how about do you think we're alone
in the cosmos no I don't think so I
don't think that the universe is just so
expansive I think it would be if you
look at probability-wise I think it's
very slim that we're we're the only ones
here do you think there's a designer to
the universe you know I used to oh oh
now I'm wearing the Atheist side but
Stephen Hawking did the did the math and
the percentage or the possibility that
we're here by chance is very very slim
so who knows and then what is the most
beautiful thing in the world human
connection and yeah deep deep human
connection and then give me an example
of deep human connection that you find
to be very profound and beautiful I
guess like this conversation and just
connecting with people on a deeper level
things like oh I'm gonna network I'm
gonna meet as many people as I kind of
like you have all wrong buddy like
networking is connecting deeply with
someone it's not just meeting as many
people as you can a lot of networking is
one's ability to apply the Pareto
principle to the networking so you need
to run around and find really quickly
the twenty
scent of people that are at the event
that are going to be able to provide the
80% of synergistic value for you and
them so that's what I aim to do as
quickly to helping other people make
those connections as well so if you
don't someone who you think could help
another person's project I think you
should absolutely introduce them Thanks
amen system love it it see and I'm
loving it all right
okay very last thought what do you think
is the deepest emotion love I would say
love and hate I guess but they're kind
of one in the same one thing yeah I have
no idea that's that's why we do this
show because I know nothing I know
nothing all I know how to do is how to
get better at asking questions awesome
that was great so we learned a lot about
about IP and about decentralizing IP
about congregating it into a scent of
well into a marketplace where we can
view it across the world and we can do
things like remove patent trolls do
things like enable more people to to
access patents and like and get them
licensed and get them used in the world
you're up to some really incredible work
and we really appreciate you sharing it
with us today on the show thanks for
coming on the show so links in the bio
check them out also join us in the
movement subscribe give us a comment
below let us know what you think go and
share this information with two people
they'll share it with two people let's
get us talking don't just consume go
create with this content make something
cool with it as well also join us on
patreon so you continue doing cool
things like come in and blockchain
economic forum of featuring really smart
people and continue to scale the efforts
to get into sports stadiums and bring
these conversations into massive arenas
so much love everyone thanks for tuning
in